well there's also like uh in schools all
these kids are
being challenged with new narratives
it's not how we grew up where you learn
u.s history it's really tricky now for
them to teach because what happens is as
a teacher i just got into this yesterday
as a teacher you're teaching elementary
school if you're going to teach us
history you got the question becomes if
you start teaching from 1776
and not 16 19 you will have stu you'll
have parents
who go
wait you know they and they can be white
or whatever they have their liberal
point of view and it becomes a debate
it's really tricky for the teacher to
have to deal with so now the teacher
teaches if you teach about being a
global citizen and being ra racism
if you bring up the term anti-racist
it's supercharged versus not racist and
these are the elementary school bro i
just was
yeah
i'm dealing with that
in in my elementary school so it becomes
a whole [ __ ] thing and it's a
balancing act so what's going on in
yeah so young people now yeah he's
actually i'm sorry he's in fourth young
people now are are i mean are being
educated it's just different and social
media is setting a different standard
they're just public shaming is a real
thing and it's keeping people there's
people
yeah
far away far away
but
it's a very powerful thing because with
young people now there's call out
culture
and call in culture which is the idea of
i'll call you out in front of everybody
or i might call you in first is it for a
private this is happening in schools so
now some student says you didn't
recognize my identity or whatever it
might be and you're being called in so
now that kid calls you in
with the teacher
and you've been called in now the next
step is to be called out in front of
everybody oh man so what happens is with
people what's the fight it's a lot to
deal with i'm like yeah you call me in
we're gonna [ __ ] correct correct that's
what we're going to do now if you do no
now now you can't you're out of school
you're out of school but also it's a lot
it's a lot to deal with man because like
how do you how do you navigate that so
what happens is on the page kids are
becoming there's a puritanical
there's there is a new puritanism in a
way because everybody is afraid everyone
i i got into it a little bit yesterday
with this teacher
the way she was teaching she was
teaching she was teaching white teacher
yes and she was teaching she had a book
on anti-racism
anti-racism versus not being racist it's
very strong fourth grade yes it's a very
strong political point of view it's
insane and what was interesting was i
was the only one to voice it and i could
tell some parents were buttholes got
tied into it other parents got super
tired i'll be so funny nobody wants to
say that to be if if they did that when
me and my friends were in fourth grade
it'd be so long it'd be so funny of
course i mean i remember like we had
teachers like telling us about gay
people
and we were delighted
it was so fun to say gay yeah we'd be
like
what is gay yeah
i mean if we had a racism class yeah oh
dude well that's cool wait can i say
what are some words i'm not allowed
that's kind of what's i have a word i
want to know if it's racist that's
what's happening
with gender now now you're talking about
now now you're you're describing
somebody as being a straight white
cisgender male 1
you have to they have yeah
well what there are two things that can
happen one is
it becomes it's hard for on the teacher
it's hard on the teacher because they
they're being pushed they're being
pulled on one and everybody's having an
argument so now how do we teach right
how do we teach what is the standard
what's the truth i'm all first teaching
true american history okay not
whitewashed but these are kids i don't
know how to do it but what also happens
is exactly what you're saying dude like
my friend's kid my my my because he goes
it's a nice butterfly and he goes he
goes look at him look at him look at him
sitting there on that pedal and his
friend goes his son goes dead
joking around goes how dare you
gender that butterfly excuse them fourth
grade but they're all [ __ ] around now
they're making fun of it oh yeah oh if
you start doing if you start making it
hush hush oh kids are going to run bro
yeah and also the kids aren't dumb like
my niece
like i was talking to her about it and
that she's in like seventh or eighth
grade and she's like yeah there's like
10 bisexual kids
yeah like dude
you're in seventh grade yeah and five
kids who identify as trans yeah so they
they see who's do you know if you were a
kid you'd see like i'm not saying
they're weird for doing that but like
you know if a kid was like i'm actually
trans man
you just don't have friends
you're doing you're just lost this is a
move you're live
back in my day you're called goth
by the way
it was god
very very true it would be called gotham
yeah yeah
but it's whatever you want to do yeah
but that's right you know let them you
know it's [ __ ] kids
they're gonna figure it they're gonna
navigate their individuality in one way
or another it's just
it's just a lot man it's a lot
there is something about
there is a lot of talk in a lot of
schools
about capitalism
being
essentially inherently racist that's
insane and you hear this all the time
that is the narrative on that side of
the equation so
you got to know when people like cloak
something that they're teaching and
we're just trying to all get along and
you go that's not what's going on yeah
you're teaching a strong political
agenda here yeah you have a bias you got
a boss you got it you got it you can't
have that you're trying to say
capitalism is racist it's a very common
thing now in the anti-racist far-left
movement you know whatever it might be
that capitalism and the structures of
even the western institutions all of
them are inherently
biased towards one
it's it's it's essentially a white
supremacy construct therefore it favors
only whites and so that may there may be
a debate there may be a conversation to
be had there hell yeah
i love it
it's